all right let's jump into this first
story we got this from The Daily Mail
really Moment The View audience gasps
when liberal host Joy Behar tells East
Ohio town where toxic Train derailed
that it had it coming after voting for
Trump
she kinda said that you know whenever I
hear stuff like this I'm like oh let me
listen to this what did she really say
and what she really said was they voted
for Trump he had this guy on his team
who was deregulating the stuff that's
what you voted for and then another one
says it's Trump's fault as if to imply
not that they deserved it but that it's
what they voted for I said the same
thing about Biden supporters but I do
not believe that what happened in East
Palestine is the fault of deregulation
or Donald Trump it's the fault of well
there's a lot of reasons that there's a
lot of problems with this one the rail
workers have been complaining about the
private companies and and safety issues
whether or not they deregulate some of
these things is not an excuse for a
company to do things poorly not to
mention you were talking about this
before the show the infrastructure bill
so when they were coming out and saying
that what were they saying that like
social justice was infrastructure
everything was infrastructure Child Care
was infrastructure that was a big one
um anything that they wanted Federal
funding for became infrastructure I
believe they said abortion was
infrastructure
um uh yeah the child care is a big one
so they were really going at any sort of
women's rights that was all women's
rights were infrastructure everything
was infrastructure except infrastructure
the railroads however they did
appropriate money for the infrastructure
bill
um in for the rails from the
infrastructure bill and I think it was
102 billion dollars went to the rails
let me let's let's play this clip maybe
it won't be it might be too mind-numbing
but we'll try playing it anyway
you want to set the audio because it
seems to me that the Republicans are
obsessed with this notion of the free
market and they don't like a lot of
regulations because it means profit get
profit but they I know these okay I'm
sorry the Family Guy joke where they're
watching The View and all the winners
it's true no the regulation is about
companies existing at all so let me just
say as we're getting through this clip
Donald Trump wanted to deregulate wanted
to put uh remove a lot of these what's
what's your bogus doing he want to get
rid of these environmental regulations
because companies couldn't operate here
at all and he needs to make them
competitive with China so what happens
is in the U.S the Democrats enact a
bunch of regulations making it too
expensive for a lot of Corporations to
exist they then move overseas where
Democrats then cut the taxes on
importing these Goods making it the only
thing they can do and and the box is
working Mr bocus went right for the
bucks he sleeps in that box anyway let's
play this clip more regulations
there were very few plane crashes thank
God and that's because the industry is
highly regulated we have to pay for
regulation and safety standards
otherwise where are we we're all going
to go up in Flames Norfolk Southern
gives as much Democrats as Republicans
it's a very powerful Lobby that is
trying to block regulation and this
train to Sarah's point two miles long
with two full-time employees and a
trainee on it
because the last Administration rolled
it down to only one having worker they
happen to have two one thing I just want
to say is I do think this was an
unforced error by President Biden it was
20 days before we had secretary Buda
judge go down 10 days before he put out
a statement acknowledging it yeah this
is Trump's country he won by 40 points
he is a president for all Americans I
believe that but he needs to show that
he is but it was time for him
who is a president for all Americans
he's saying is she saying Biden is yeah
this is like the canned fake it's just
it's uttered by the way he plays someone
with deep ties to the chemical industry
in charge of the epa's chemical safety
office that's who you voted for in that
District Donald Trump who reduces all
safety he did McDonald's voters saw
something on the ground that probably
resonates
and say who's doing the job here forget
about the photo ops showing up is a big
showing up I think I think this is
Donald Trump's fault good I think this
is Donald Trump's fault so wait I think
as we are watching but Mr bocus peed
ran into a corner and peed a little bit
or a little jerk I was trying to listen
to Joy Behar and I'm looking at Mr
boca's starfish I was like this is
awkward so Jack besobic tweeted Joy
Behar says East Palestine got what they
deserved because they voted for Trump
that's who you voted for and then Brian
krasenstein says nowhere in the clip did
she say that's what they deserved so but
like Jack didn't quote her he's implying
that's what she was saying and he's not
wrong it's a little strong I would say
yeah but she's basically saying you
voted for it that's what happens I say
this all the time I say you vote for
Biden you get what you deserve sure you
deserve what you asked for but I don't
believe what happened in East Palestine
is a problem with Donald Trump because
Joe Biden has been president now for two
years and so what like that the two
years Joe Biden was trapped in that that
Cube or whatever that that sheep that
the the Zod got trapped in in Superman 2
or whatever like he's been frozen in
time like uh spinning through space
unable to enact any of these policies
unable to fix anything and then after
the train to Roman happens he's he's
frozen in ice and and booty judge was a
fell into a crevice somewhere and they
were just they were trying to get there
but they really couldn't it's still
Trump's fault Biden's been president for
two years how is it Trump's fault what
is wrong with these people they're
insane here's the problem too it's like
because the Democrats always believe in
regulation they make it so that our
industry our domestic industry
particular infrastructure industry
including Airlines as well as uh
Railways are not competitive globally so
then they turn around and they say okay
well we have to have harsh regulations
to protect for liability for disasters
the truth of the matter is if you if you
allowed them to just compete on an even
playing field they wouldn't need all
these liability protections but because
they now have them they they behave in
ways that are are extraordinarily
Reckless and then they're offered
liability Shields by the very government
that is allegedly regulating them at the
end of the day the only people that get
hurt are the people in these towns and
it's just tragic
mind-numbingly annoying yes that no
matter what happens it's Donald Trump's
fault it's like my my guy it is two
three it is two two three two zero two
three that's the date it is February 23
2023 25 months it has been 25 months
since Donald Trump was in office not to
mention there's a lame duck session and
they're like well clearly the train
wreck that happened you know a couple
weeks ago Trump's fault Trump's fault
that it happened because uh you know all
the things Trump did Biden just didn't
know right you know until now and I
believe it was a billion dollars that
they passed for infrastructure in
December of 21. that was you know
Biden's bill that's what he wanted he
got it and then you have all these
disasters and they still managed to
Pivot to blame Trump it's just it's just
on its face I like how the audience
gasped when they heard yeah I mean
that's most of the audience leans
towards Joy behar's politics I would
assume and that was even kind of
startling for them well the issue is
it's what I've been talking about for a
while that when you build an audience
they expect you to give them what they
want to hear and so the view has
cultivated Trump derangement syndrome
it's going to be it's it's gonna like
Trump's gonna be dead it's gonna be like
50 years in the future and the president
is going to be you know part of the
cyborg Democrat Party or something and
his name is going to be like zyborg and
they're going to be like well clearly
this is Trump's fault like yeah cyborg
Obama they'll be blaming the Deep fix of
trump
Trump's fault I mean if you want to get
scary and talk about like 1984 ask and
and creating a villain for everyone to
Rally around I wouldn't be surprised if
they did start deep faking some kind of
Perpetual villain imagine what they
could do now imagine what they could do
then with videos of terrorists or
whatever they could make a video of
someone and say oh we found this in a
cave somewhere here's what here's I'm
saying and people just believe it yeah
we'll probably hit a point where they
create the first digital the villain
like a real not even a real ever was a
real person it'll be a completely
fictitious character and everyone
they'll just get enough people to
believe it and right now they have Trump
and he's real and they just ride it out
and and he's still in the spotlight and
so anything he does is still can be
villainized why do you think this is my
best my best guess is that they're so
confused and terrified about the future
of the economics in the country that
they're just just blaming they need a
villain they need a villain so that they
can have a hero or they can be the hero
and their villain is and they tried to
do DeSantis and they tried to do Tucker
Carlson and none of it worked I tried
Rogan Joe Rogan yeah kind of I don't I
don't think really like they really
tried Tucker and and DeSantis
during the coveted period it seemed like
they really went after Rogan for a
couple months and then everyone's like
we've listened to this guy talk for
thousands of hours you're not going to
convince us otherwise but I agree I mean
Trump I think is clearly the he's the
he's the galvanizing whipping post of
our society like that's that's what they
use to beat every time they screw up
terribly and they can still say well you
guys screwed up and you voted for this
clown for four years and now
everything's a disaster because of him
the reality is it's almost none of it's
Trump's fault none of the things he
wanted to do got done because he had the
Deep State working against him the
entire time he couldn't do anything like
he didn't do anything everybody was
working against him Trump should be we
should give it a new definition a a
trump as a scapegoat that is actually
the solution of the problem at the cause
of right so then you can say like well
that's clearly a trump you know they're
they're blaming someone for the problem
who's actually been fixing it and then
there's got to be inverse of Biden a
Biden is the person who causes the
problem and they defend and claim he's
solving it yeah Putin's a trump and uh
she's a Biden whenever I get people with
to tell me that they can't stand Donald
Trump I'll tell them well particularly
one things I love about what he did his
president was getting us out of
trans-pacific partnership he signed it
away really quick there's this thing
called the investor State dispute
settlement clause and that uh
trans-pacific partnership the deal where
they're going to allow Malaysian oil
companies and other corporations to sue
the American government for
discrimination if we chose not to buy
their oil or something they could sue
our country and then we as taxpayers
would have to pay these fines to these
corporations and they were trying to put
that through Obama was trying to pass
that and basically make Us corporate
service serves
um and then Trump immediately for
whatever reason ended it and when I tell
people that and and much more succinctly
they they almost always are like
jaw-droppingly
the left to find that out the left was
opposing the TPP but this is a during
the weird shift period where the left
used to be Pro Assange anti-war anti-tpp
and then Trump came around and all of a
sudden it started to shift and invert
now the left is pro-war anti-assage
anti-free speech they're basically
neocons but you know and antibody bodily
autonomy I mean it's quite the shift
it's horrifying man this is why I as
much as I detest Trump for totally
opposite reason I had to test him
because he surrounded himself with the
swamp when he was allegedly draining it
he didn't do any of that he didn't fire
fauci he uh was it worse than say Obama
no was it worse than Clinton probably
not was it worse than Bush no but he was
worse than Reagan but he ran on being
I'll take it he ran on being my guy
though sure I mean I I was thinking
about this earlier and I'm like Donald
Trump John Bolton uh you know the the
the worst possible guy to bring in uh
what what else you know he he smack
talks I don't know what did Donald Trump
do that has people so mad at him
and the reality is he pissed off the
establishment by fighting against them
no that explains why the cult is against
him but then I hear people like you know
Luke for instance who's like you know he
did this or Dave Smith you know Trump is
bad he did you know drone strikes he
expanded this he blah blah blah bump
stocks bump stock Donnie and all that
I'm like yup yup yup all that okay now
let's go back in time to Obama gun
control yup War yup more war oh way more
War uh housing crisis how about big
Banker bailouts okay let's go back to
George W bush Dick Cheney Iraq war and
Afghanistan being started
um directive 51 come on that's all
there's a whole bunch of let's go back
to Clinton now
I was much too young to know too much
about Clinton but I know enough about
Clinton and the things he did and they
want to accuse Trump of being nasty yo
Bill Clinton did it when he was in
office come on the problem is that
Donald Trump said nasty words don't get
me started on Bill Clinton I I look at
what you know George W bush and Obama
are the presidents in my adult life and
the bad things they did and Trump is
infinitely better than they were so
people come out and they say oh Trump
did this thing bad this thing bad this
thing bad this thing bad and I'm like oh
wow those are like substantially less
bad than Obama and George W bush Clinton
and Reagan Reagan he brought a no-fault
divorce and gun control come on I don't
know why everybody celebrates Reagan but
I don't look I was a baby when Reagan
was around then we got George H.W bush
we got what Desert Storm with that guy
it just seems like it's all trash you're
right and then you get Donald Trump like
it's pretty good well it's
if it weren't for 2020 I could probably
agree with you but when he passes
trillions of dollars in those stimulus
bills and he permits fauci this little
Gremlin Tyrant to lock us down it's like
no you can no longer you can no longer
be looked at in any positive light you
allowed the entire world because they
followed in America's footsteps to
essentially derail the global economy
that is a catastrophic mistake but but I
I look at it not like you can't just say
president good bad it's it's like what
did they do that was good what did they
do that was bad can you can you guys
think of anything Obama did that was
good
if I if you give me an hour maybe I
can't he's the president of the TPP the
trans-pacific partnership right so it's
more International Trade these are laws
that get enacted on the American people
without proper legislation because oh we
have to abide by the treaty that means
this country has to do these things like
we're forced to go to war because of
NATO the American people the the
Congress can only declare war but
because of NATO so that's what they
tried doing Obama had the ndaa
indefinite detention provision they
could rendition you into a black site
off uh outside of the country
indefinitely they sign that this dude
had a whole bunch big Banker bailouts
Occupy Wall Street was protesting him so
I look at Donald Trump and I'm like fine
how about we say this
Trump's a negative 12. Obama was a
negative 56. George W Bush was negative
84. Clinton was a negative 80. it's like
so Trump is he's bad but he's like the
least bad and closer we got to good I
totally agree but then I look at foreign
policy and I'm like he's actually the
best yes
hands down and didn't didn't Ron Paul
would have been better yes of course
didn't Trump get us out of uh the Paris
Accord and the Iran deal like didn't
didn't Trump get us out of both those
that's great Biden brought us right back
oh yeah he brought us right back yeah
and they're getting out of the Iran deal
was good why was that good
am I the only one that was on the end of
what is it what is this
the Iran nuclear deal was to they had
basically agreed to have their their
nuclear facilities inspected and I
thought that was a great thing why why
do we want to have a catalyst for war
with them I think the inspection and
treaty is potentially a catalyst for war
with them
well I think I think that if you're
inspecting it then you know that they're
not creating nuclear weapons there's no
you know uh imperative to strike so who
who uh who uh enacted who is the
president which Administration brought
about the Iran nuclear deal I thought it
was Obama was it Obama I thought so and
which Administration produced stuxnet to
blow up Iranian centrifuges probably I
think it was Obama too so look I got to
be honest I probably don't know enough
about the specifics in the deal other
than I'm typically anti-interventionist
and if they don't give me a good reason
why they're engaging in these kinds of
policies sure so I can only say this you
know fair point I don't know enough
about it but I'm certainly not going to
trust Obama who enacts a treaty and then
blows them up I agree man and you
shouldn't trust them and that's why you
can't give them any of these guys a ton
of credit for anything that they do but
I'll Grant you yes Trump is probably the
best president of my lifetime we still
had 2020 which was maybe the worst year
of my lifetime yeah but it's the
governors who did it you know you can
blame Trump for a lot I mean she got rid
of Berk she got rid of fauci he
shouldn't have promoted lockdowns in the
first place that gave the launching
Point yes to these Governors and he
probably could have used some emergency
powers to stop some of it
but it was ultimately the governors and
Donald Trump took a constitutional
approach where he was like look 10th
Amendment I can't the governor is going
to do it the states have the right to do
their thing and and legislate the way
they want the reason the Libertarians
are so hard on Trump for that period is
because of our understanding of Austrian
economics and the the trillions that he
allowed to be created in the thin air
that we're now suffering the
inflationary process to this day and yes
it's not entirely his fault and yes he
wasn't responsible for all of it but if
he's going to go up there and say that
I'm I'm here to drain the swap I am
going to point to you and let you know
that the media is full of crap and I'm
going to be the one guy that tells you
the truth and then you allow the biggest
Liars on earth like Anthony fauci to go
up there and just lie to us for a year
straight and you don't fire him when you
have a chance sorry there's just a
disconnect there that I can't remember
it's bad sure but I'm just saying like
I'm just relatively I'm just kind of
over it because because everything else
is terrible because everything else was
a hundred-fold worse and I created a
bunch of really good things yeah and I
look at what's going on now in East
Palestine and I'm just like now I just
like the guy like I saw the video of him
at McDonald's talking about him knowing
the menu better and I'm like I just I
just like this guy so much better than
these other pieces of trash thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time